Oui aussi
quand nous-mêmes
Oui
[Musique]
idéal
voir le succès
et externe une conversation
de son ancienne édition botinera n'est pas non
Quoi
non
tu peux être entier
bon
Oui
[Musique]
et ainsi que boire
de la formation des graines
action
étaient
de cette résolution
en action s'est passé
si tu t'habilles
[Musique]
ça
en tout
Oui
[Musique]
je
seul
avant de
n'existe pas
sept
civilisation
c'est une réponse d'amour
cet age
[Musique]
tu seras servi
Oui
voyons les groupes pédagogiques
De quelque chose
[Musique]
et marchandise
nous serons une côte
pour voir si à la fin de l'instruction
[Musique]
Oui
Il ne faut pas que cela passe comme ca
à partir de la version
et nous utilisons du contenu
ou
[Musique]
nous sommes dans notre débat
C'est ce qu'on appelle la loi et nous aurions la subsistance
Achats
Oui
[Musique]
je
supplémentaire
[Musique]
que les chinois
supprimer les autres difficiles qui ne le sont pas
ces appels s'adressent
après la ville
deux
administrations confortables
Oui
[Musique]
ensuite
dans ta troisième ville
bon
plus
Oui
de suivi
fonctions de l'axe x au sol
destination que la crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]